today on gamespot news call of duty
vanguard's file size gets revealed
blizzcon gets cancelled and nintendo is
working with pikmin again i'm davonte
chisholm and you're watching gamespot
news
are you the type of gamer that sheds a
tier every time they have to delete
something to make room for a call of
duty update yes well it looks like you
won't have to cry for much longer
activision has announced that the file
size for call of duty vanguard will be
quote significantly smaller than
previous entries in the series
in a tweet activision said vanguard uses
new on-demand texture streaming tech to
help save up to 50 percent of storage
space on playstation 5 xbox series x and
s as well as pc in the past games like
call of duty warzone and black ops cold
war among others have been called out
for their large file sizes that only
grow bigger with ongoing updates
at one point call of duty modern warfare
in its entirety took over 250 gigs of
space this morning in a blog post call
of duty published their pre-load
instructions as well as file sizes for
each console
in more activision blizzard news
overwatch gets an update and perhaps the
biggest takeaway is that mccree is now
cole cassidy same hero new name oh and
blizzcon 2022 is cancelled blizzard made
the change because mccree's namesake
jesse mccree was ousted from the company
amid the sexual harassment and
discrimination case at activision
blizzard going forward blizzard said it
will not name new characters after
blizzard employees and vowed to be quote
more thoughtful and discerning about
adding real world references in future
overwatch content adding to this the
developer also announced that players
can now change their battle tag for free
for a limited time normally battle tag
changes cost 10
but you can request a new name for no
cost at all until november 5th and all
you have to do is fill out this customer
support form but keep in mind this won't
stack if you already have a free name
change that you haven't used yet oh and
you know the february 2022 online
blizzcon well it's been canceled however
blizzard did say despite the lack of an
event it will still be making
announcements and providing updates for
its games in that month and when it
comes to the reason for cancellation
blizzard said in part we feel the energy
it would take to put on a show like this
is best directed towards supporting our
teams and progressing development of our
games and experiences additionally we
would also like to take the time to
reimagine what a blizzcon event in the
future could look like
alright switching gears from what's been
canceled to what's been delayed
after a bit of a slow year the division
2 team has released a new road map for
the future of the game and unfortunately
for fans it pushes back the next big
update to february of 2022 during the
wait players will get more behind the
scenes updates from the dev team with
the return of the intelligence annex
series of deep dive articles into
upcoming features and changes
are you guys out there still into the
division 2 and holding out for these
updates if not what game pulled your
attention let me know in the comments
[Music]
finally some good news for pikmin fans
nintendo and niantic have announced
their next mobile app pikmin bloom
considing with the 20th anniversary of
nintendo's nature-based franchise the
game sees players enter a world of lush
green earth one where pikmin can sprout
and grow via player steps pikmin are
grown from seedlings which are planted
into a special slot in the player's
backpack so steps can be registered each
pikmin takes 1 000 steps to sprout after
which they can be pulled and become part
of the player's pikmin squad you can
also name each pikmin you pull a first
for the franchise that gives an extra
bit of personality to your pikmin
congrats to all the pikmin fans out
there this is huge news will you be
playing the new niantic game let me know
in the comments as for me i think i
should give it a shot i haven't left the
house in two years that's no good on
behalf of devonte chisholm and persia
i'm richie signing off i gotta go make
space on this thing see you next time
you